Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Ich habe übrigens mal in meinem Kaffeesatz nachgeschaut und festgestellt, dass es gar keine massenhafte Überwachung gibt.
Hast du? Hast du aber wahrscheinlich ein bisschen zu tief ins Glas geschaut, ne?
Lokbuchnetzpolitik, hundertneunundfünfzig Ausgaben haben schon das Licht der Welt erblickt und während Dinos noch sein Mikrofon testet.
Ja, ich wollte nur die Räusper-Taste ausprobieren.
Ist gut, oder?
Hat aber irgendwie anfangs nicht funktioniert. Na ja.
Der muss halt ein bisschen die will halt auch ein bisschen lieb gehabt werden. So,
Tastenstreichler, du. Ja, vom Kaffeesatz zum Datensatz ist es äh manchmal gar nicht so weit äh entfernt, ja? Vielleicht sollte man später einfach mal direkt gleich in der Kaffeebank nachschlagen.
Wenn man Erkenntnisse äh gewinnen will über diesen Planeten? Was heute nicht so gute Laune, ne?
Nee, ich habe äh.
Obwohl wir, obwohl wir, obwohl wir so einen schönen Film gesehen haben.
Ja, der war schön. Wir haben einen schönen Film gesehen.
Genau, wir waren im Rausch der Daten waren wir.
Democracy im Rausch der Daten. Wir hatten den ja hier schon mal äh ganz unauffällig eingestreut erwähnt, dass es den gibt.
Genau. Und dann erreicht er uns dann auch noch eine Mail, dass äh es eine ein Premierenabend geben würde in verschiedenen Städten,
Beziehungsweise hat man glaube ich auch schon drauf hingewiesen, aber dann genauer dann gab's noch den Hinweis, dass man sich auch noch ein Ticket ticken kann und das äh geschah dann auch. Und da war dann so,
Die äh Kleinprominenz vollständig angetreten hat. Ich so einen Eindruck.
Ja, Berliner Berliner Netzpolitik, Interessenten und.
War übrigens noch nie in der Urania. Ist mir in dem Moment eingefallen.
Ich konnte mich aber nicht mehr dran erinnern. Ich war da irgendwann aus irgendwie.
Ist er auch seltener. Ja, ist hübsch da.
Nee, jetzt weiß ich wieder, warum ich da mal war. Irgendeine Konferenz. Aber da war äh war sehr schönes Theater. Ähm,
und ein schöner, also ein interessanter Film, muss man einfach mal sagen. Der äh gut gemacht war von diesem Regisseur.
Zuerst studiert, David Bennet gesagt ja.
David Bernit. Ja, der äh hat einen schönen Film gemacht in schwarz-weiß. Über ähm,
Die Datenschutzreform und äh den Reporteur des EU-Parlamentes Jan-Philipp Albrecht und seinen Mitarbeiter Ralf Bendrad.
Der auch hier schon mal zu Worte gekommen ist.
Genau, zu diesem Thema auch. Ralf ist ja eine coole Socke,
Das hat man den Film auch gesehen und Jan Philipp Albrecht auch und es war und Vivian Reding auch und wer wie sind nicht alle heißen? Ich fand den Film wie gesagt,
sehr aufschlussreich immer auch so zu sehen wie so ein,
wie dieser Prozess abläuft, war. Äh es wurde natürlich kritisiert, okay, der Film geht ja im Prinzip nur durch die ersten beiden Phasen, ja, irgendwie äh Vorschlag von der,
Kommission kommt Parlament.
Reagiert, benennt einen.
Handelt und dann geht's in geht's ja zum Rat, zum Trilog quasi und der Rat äh beim Rad.
Wird dann alles kaputt gemacht.
Wird dann alles äh umgedreht und dann haben wir am Ende genau das, was wir nicht wollten. Aber dieser Teil fehlt noch, weil der ist noch nicht geschehen. Das haben sie sich aufbewahrt, damit wir nächstes Jahr auch noch Gründe haben, überhaupt noch Sendungen zu machen.
Ja, ich meine, ansonsten sieht's ja jetzt grade nicht besonders gut aus, ne?
Ja
Ja, also Film kann man empfehlen. Ich denke, also ich denke, einmal so diesen Prozess EU da zu sehen und dann auch diese diese netzpolitische Komponente und.
Also insbesondere den Prozess EU-Parlament, also das das ist ja sozusagen das, worauf's äh fokussiert. Um vielleicht auch mal kurz so erzählen, was da eigentlich passiert. Also dies äh Dokuteam hat sich halt,
entschlossen diesem Thema zu folgen, was ich schon mal eine ganz bemerkenswerte Idee finde, weil.
Ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau was, wann haben Sie wann sind Sie eingestiegen? Die haben ja schon die,
schon den Moment, wo er ernannt wurde, auch live gefilmt gehabt, war das,
oder war das erst danach und war das weiß nicht mehr so ganz genau. Auf jeden Fall sind sie.
Fängt der Film im Prinzip mit der Benennung von Jan-Philipp Albrecht als äh als Berichterstatter an,
und begleitet dann ähm ihn Ralf, andere Leute, relativ nah. Meint er danach irgendwie auf der Bühne auch so äh,
das Mikrofon die ganze Zeit dabei gehabt und irgendwann einfach nicht mehr drüber nachgedacht, dass sie aufgezeichnet wurden, so, dass das irgendwie hoch ins Klo getragen hat und nicht abgeschaltet hat, also das äh,
handelte sich dann wohl schon um ein ganz intimes Verhältnis, was da aufgebaut wurde. Auf jeden Fall schön zu sehen, wie diese ganze ähm,
ähm Bildensbildung dort stattfindet und das was auch hier immer mal wieder Anklang so unsere kleine EU-Romantik,
dass es schon so ein ganz andere Konsens, einen ganz anderen Konsensdruck gibt im Europäischen Parlament,
nicht so sehr geprägt wie die Parlamente auf nationaler Ebene, wie wir das hier aus Deutschland, aus anderen Ländern äh gewohnt sind. Und ja, nur.
Schon richtig gesagt hast. Wir haben's jetzt gerade bei der Netzneutralität gesehen,
Was nützt der tollste Parlament äh Konsens, wenn das Ganze dann einfach aus den letzten Metern letzten Endes wieder diesen nationalen Regierungen zum Fraß vorgeworfen wird, weil das kam dann eigentlich in dem Film auch sehr schön raus, so diese Zurückhaltung,
dass man sie einfach klar machen muss, die Leute, die sich wirklich permanent auf europäischer äh Ebene Gedanken machen und die dort im Parlament auch diesen,
im gesamteuropäischen Eindruck ausgesetzt sind, weil sie eben täglich mit Leuten aus aller Herren Länder,
tun haben und deren Zwänge und Bedürfnisse genauso kennen wie alle eben auch diesen Gesamtwunsch Europa äh kennen, sitzen halt im Rat, Leute, die treffen sich,
ein paar Mal im Jahr und verbringen eigentlich die ganze Zeit,
mit ihrer Peergroup in ihren Heimatländern und sind eigentlich im Rat da, um am Ende nationale Interessen oder nationale Regierungsinteressen durchzusetzen, muss man auch mal dazu sagen.
Ja und da zerbricht es halt einfach und im Prinzip schreit das nach einer fortgesetzten Reform der EU,
hier einfach noch sehr viel mehr ähm Stimmgewalt ins europäische Parlament legen muss.
Ja. Wobei jetzt, was diese Zerwirkungsprozess auf diese Datenschutzreform angeht, ähm habe ich mich gestern noch,
War gestern, ja. Gestern mit äh Ralf noch drüber unterhalten, dass.
Also er sagt, er ist eigentlich guter Dinge, dass,
dass momentan in der EU bestehende Datenschutzniveau nicht gesenkt wird im am Ende dieses Prozesses und dass das quasi sogar für Deutschland unter Umständen eine Erhöhung,
Bedeutet, wir haben jetzt quasi in diesen in diesen Verhandlungen den den größeren Teil der.
Einzelabsätze, über die ja dann da debattiert wird durch. Und ähm er hat dann quasi.
Ist eigentlich guter Dinge und man würde ja erwarten, dass jemand, der so viel Erfahrung in diesem Bereich hat, äh wenn der nicht guter Dinge ist, dass er da oder dass er guten Grund hätte, nicht guter Dinge zu sein,
und das auch Absehen und erkennen könnte, wenn er nicht guter Dinge sein muss. Also, was ich meine?
Ich lasse das jetzt mal so stehen.
Also wir empfehlen den Film, das war interessant und ähm wir wir kennen die. Wir kennen die, äh das ist der Disclaimer.
Genau.
Kenne ich aus dem Fernsehen.
Wir kennen die die bereuten Leute vom Film jetzt. Wir sind nämlich deren Peergroup.
Ja, wir kennen die Filmstars auch, ja.
Ja, kommen wir äh weg von den Hollywood-Themen hin zum grauen Alltag. Zum graulichen Alltag im Parlamentsgeschehen.
Ich hatte mich ja letzte Woche noch.
Eigentlich ganz positiv über den Graulich-Bericht geäußert und gesagt, dass er erstmal einen ganz guten Eindruck macht und äh das hat zumindest relativ viele Informationen drin waren aus meinem ersten Dafürhalten.
Oder hat sie's noch nicht gelesen.
Ist nur äh stellenweise gelesen und dann,
Haben wir ja trotzdem mit großer Spannung erwartet, dass der gute Herr Graulich am Donnerstag in den NSA Untersuchungsausschuss kommt, wo er dann sein in dreifacher Ausführung verfassten äh Bericht vorstellen würde.
Und am Vorabend äh schrieb dann äh Thorsten Denker war das, glaube ich, auf äh Süddeutsche äh ja,
die wirklich rechtlich relevanten Teile dieses Berichts.
Die sind einfach von von dem BND abgeschrieben. Wortgleich. Ähm und zwar ging es im Prinzip um äh zwei Rechtsfragen, die ihr in diesem Gutachten ja auch behandelt hat.
Und zwar die Weltraumtheorie, also.
Wir dürfen alles äh abschnorcheln, ohne dass deutsche Gesetze gelten, weil das kommt ja aus dem Welt.
Ist ja im Weltraum, deswegen stehen diese Daten,
da gilt einfach im Prinzip alles nicht, insbesondere nicht das Grundgesetz, es ist ja im Weltraum und zum anderen den Umgang mit Metadaten, weil der BND,
quasi die Rechtsauffassung vertritt, dass die grundsätzlich nicht personenbezogen seien und deswegen ja uneingeschränkt verwendbar. Beide Auffassungen sind natürlich,
Kaum zu halten. Und es gibt entsprechende.
Interne Rechtsgutachten, die der BND wirklich mit einer heißen Nadel gestrickt hat, als dieses Thema. Ähm ich ich weiß nicht genau, in welchem Jahr zweitausenddreizehn war das, glaube ich, aufkam. Und da wurden dann beim BND relativ.
Relativ ähm schnell und harthastig irgendwelchen Begründungen dafür gegeben, warum das ja in Ordnung ist.
Diese Begründung hat der Graulich in seinem Report einfach drin.
Ich verstehe leider die Frage nicht.
Also was für Begründungen hat er so zum.
Die habe ich also ähm,
dass die Weltraumtheorie wird damit begründet, dass es ein äh dass die Daten im Weltraum erhoben werden,
und diese Metadatenerfassung wird damit äh begründet, dass Meterdaten nicht personenbezogen sind,
Also diese beiden hat ja quasi äh diese Begründung hat er eins zu eins in seinem Report drin. Und.
Diese internen Dokumente, in denen diese Begründungen waren, hat der Denker eben auch mit anderem mit anderen Briefkopf vorliegen konnte, also quasi daher das Plagiat äh genau ähm,
erkennen und weiß dann auch darauf hin, dass in diesen abgeschriebenen Teilen oder in den plaggierten Teilen äh,
vergleiche, also das Wort vergleiche mit VER, GL abgekürzt wird,
Und er im sonst in seinem sonstigen Bericht immer VGL als Abkürzung für Vergleiche nimmt
was natürlich auch ein sehr schöner Hinweis für die unterschiedlichen Autoren ist. Und das war natürlich jetzt großes Diskussionsthema in diesem Ausschuss und der Graulich sagt natürlich jo ähm,
Selbstverständlich hat er nicht alles selber geschrieben, dass er auch keine wissenschaftliche Arbeit. Ähm natürlich hat er Zuarbeiten, hatte er
Zuarbeiter, das hatten wir auch schon gesagt, eben die Leute vom BND, die freundlicherweise da geholfen haben.
Den Bericht so zu verfassen und das war ja auch sein Fazit, das war ja dem BND erstmal ganz genehm, dass der das Fazit des Reports war ja, dass der Graulich ankündigt, ja ich kann bestätigen, dass BND hat sich nicht an den äh die NSA hat sich nicht an die Vereinbarung gehalten
die sie mit dem BND hatte. Tada! Äh bitteschön Untersuchungsausschuss. Ich die NSA war vertragsbrüchig. Ich kann das jetzt.
Arme BND.
Der arme BND war das Opfer, ja.
Ja. Oh Mann. So. Ich habe ein bisschen Mitleid jetzt. Schnuff.
Also ich wäre ungerne in seiner Situation gewesen, in dieser Ausschusssitzung, aber wie berichtet wird.
Ähm hat er sich da wohl relativ ähm.
Überzeugt von dem, was er getan hat, gegeben und hat in diesem Untersuchungsausschuss, ist ja wohl relativ arrogant aufgetreten und ähm hat da seine Kritiker relativ barsch.
Abgewatscht. Ähm interessant ist natürlich dazu.
Der Graulich war ja bestellt von der Bundesregierung. Sein Auftraggeber war quasi die Bundesregierung.
Und für die hat er sicherlich auch einen ganz guten Job gemacht, ne. Jene Vertreter der Opposition, insbesondere natürlich so Konstantin von Notz, ähm,
Ströbele, Martina Renner, hatten sich ja grundsätzlich gegen diese Idee eines,
vertrauensmannes, einer Vertrauensperson gewehrt und deren Kritik ist hier natürlich äh im vollen Umfang,
als als gerechtfertigt.
Nachvollziehbar,
der Sport ist ja auch noch nicht ganz beendet, also die Klage liegt weiß nicht in welchem Zustand das gerade ist, aber man will halt auch Verfassungsgerichtsebene dagegen vorgehen, gegen diesen Vorgang hatten wir auch schon ein paar Mal erwähnt.
Mal gespannt, wie lange das überhaupt dauert und wenn wenn das vor allem kommt, was das dann nochmal für diesen Ausschuss äh bedeuten kann.
Also das ist schon echt das ist schon echt Bärenstark. Also,
lässt sie dir wirst du bestellt als unabhängige Vertrauensperson, arbeitest die ganze Zeit mit diesem BND-Leuten da zusammen, lässt dir von denen Bericht schreiben, in dem sie selber ihr rechtliches ähm.
Ihre rechtliche Argumentation einfach dir in den Bericht reinschreiben und er hat sich dann quasi noch in dem Ausschuss hingesetzt und hat gesagt, so, ja ja klar ist das von denen,
hat er auch irgendwo stehen, nach Auffassung des BND und das wäre aber jetzt auch völlig in Ordnung, weil es wäre ja auch seine Auffassung.
Insofern sagt er, klar hat jemand anders geschrieben, steht aber mein Name drunter, wir sind hier nicht, ist keine Doktorarbeit, insofern ist das völlig in Ordnung. Ich stehe für das, was da steht.
So sieht er das jetzt völlig in Ordnung, ne?
Ich finde das schon echt, ich finde das wirklich, wirklich ähm erschütternd und beschämend, dass sowas irgendwie,
da passiert, dass dass wir uns sowas anschauen und das in im Prinzip sogar äh nach den Erfahrungen der letzten Jahre halt noch nicht mal mehr sonderlich skandalös finden, dass uns das sowas passiert.
Ja, dass man sagt, haben wir, dass man im Prinzip sagen kann, ja, haben wir doch gesagt, dass das so laufen würde. Klar. Aber die machen sich noch nicht mal mehr die Mühe, die hätten das ja wenigstens umschreiben können,
Ja, dann hätte man äh hätte man am Ende sagen können, jo.
Ist inhaltlich das Gleiche, da habt ihr euch wahrscheinlich relativ lange und sehr genau drüber unterhalten.
Ich sehe das ja eh so wie ihr, schreibt ihr das mal, dann dann kümmere ich mich schon mal um den anderen Kram.
Und das war ja der entscheidende äh auch ein entscheidender,
Punkt, den er beachten sollte, diese Themen, ja? Geht er einfach zum BND und sagt, ja hier, Instrued hier, ja, paste mal da euer Rechtsgutachten von Dance, dann und wann.
Hatte er da nicht auch noch etwas? Nö, abweichende Meinung, ähm warum er denn überhaupt eingesetzt worden sei, aufgrund welcher ähm Verfehlung.
Genau, es gab ähm dann Debatten.
Ne
Genau. Äh genau, das war sehr schön. Äh da wurde er dann zu Alconal befragt von natürlich Vertretern der Opposition,
Ähm und hat dann gesagt, Alconal wäre jetzt also nicht Teil seiner seines Untersuchungsauftrags gewesen, hätte er sich deshalb nicht mit auseinandergesetzt, dass es eben nicht war.
Nicht wahr. Der hat äh quasi in seinem Auftrag, war genau drin, so schau dir diese Sache an und so weiter, ja, hat er nicht gemacht.
Und meint aber jetzt seine seine Tätigkeit wäre jetzt erfüllt.
Ja, ja, der ist zufrieden mit sich. Der ruht in sich, wie wir quasi von den Leuten, die dort waren, geschildert wurde, dass das eigentlich Schockierende ist, dass dieser Mann noch nicht mal rot geworden ist.
Ja und äh wahrscheinlich das ist auch die,
Mehrheit im Untersuchungsausschuss in Form der Vertreter der Regierungskoalition jetzt auch nicht so der Meinung, dass es alles scheiße gelaufen wäre, sondern fühlt sich jetzt bestätigt und,
Ja, wenn das so ist, dann haben wir ja jetzt hier Klärung, dann können wir jetzt mal weitermachen.
Genau, kann die Opposition jetzt mal in die Fresse halten. Dann können wir jetzt mal weiterarbeiten.
Genau. Also mit anderen Worten diese Episode mit dem Herrn Graulich hat im Prinzip den Einblick in diese ganze Direktorengeschichte,
verhindert bis zum aktuellen Zeitpunkt. Es gab keinen wirklichen Einblick, sondern der einzige Einblick, den es gab, war der Einblick
Einer Person, die nicht Teil dieses Untersuchungsausschusses ist, der kein Problem damit hat, seinen Kaffee sich vom äh BND
zubereiten zu lassen, weil er sowieso grad bei ihm im Gebäude äh sitzt in so einem schönen Bereich und sich dann den ganzen Tag mit anderen BND Mitarbeitern über die potenziellen Verfilmungen des BND unterhalten kann,
Und wir wissen ja, wie gut so was funktioniert. Wenn du da kritische Haltung einnehmen willst,
und äh das Einzige, was er wirklich gesehen hat, waren halt die paar Selektoren,
Ich sage jetzt ein paar, weil's ja irgendwie von vierzigtausend die Rede ist im Vergleich zu Millionen. Ähm,
die halt der BND meint, na ja, die wären halt nicht zulässig,
Wäre es eigentlich sehr viel interessanter gewesen wäre, sich mal die anzuschauen, von denen der BND meinte, sie wären zulässig, weil da liegen ja die eigentlichen Verfehlungen drin. Also die potenziellen Verfehlungen drin,
könnte es jetzt zum Beispiel ja sagen wir mal in diesen Selektoren wären Sachen drin gewesen, die okay gewesen wären, da wäre das her, ist nicht weiter schlimm gewesen,
Also das ist äh sozusagen das das Graulich äh Segment dieses Ausschusses,
ist es, damit es eigentlich schon richtig zu Ende. Also der fährt jetzt wieder in Urlaub, oder wie?
Also der Graulich meint, er hätte jetzt seine Arbeit getan und wäre damit jetzt durch und die Opposition muss jetzt halt den Rechtsweg bestreiten, der die,
Die Koalition,
betrachtet das Thema damit jetzt mehr oder weniger als erledigt. Ähm die Opposition äh verständlicherweise nicht.
Und äh was jetzt die rechtlichen Einschätzungen von dem angeht, okay, die sind natürlich, ich meine, das kann man natürlich auch hochhängen oder nicht. Es heißt jetzt nicht oder noch sind wir noch nicht an dem Punkt, dass der Abschlussbericht des.
NSA und das das erste Untersuchungsausschusses, diese Stellen von Graulichkeit auch nochmal plagiert hat. Ja, also theoretisch könnte es sein, dass äh der Ausschuss ja auch entgegen der,
Also eine andere Auffassung erlangt als ihre Vertrauensperson, als eine Vertrauensperson. Wahrscheinlich ist es nicht, aber so diese diese Nebelkerze, diese ganze Selektorennummer über Monate.
In die Debatte zu ziehen, dann diesen Graulichter hin zu zu schicken, der dann irgendeine irgendeine,
BND-Sockenpuppe im Prinzip ist, das hat jetzt erstmal geklappt. So, ne? Und irgendwann, so, irgendwann wird ja auch die Zeit knapp für so eine Untersuchungsausschuss und ähm das ja, hat, hat im Zweifel muss man wahrscheinlich sagen
funktioniert. So. Ist ein absoluter Skandal, ist eine absolute Frechheit, ist ein Witz.
Aber keiner regt.
Aber die die Opposition muss jetzt da halt irgendwie auch mal.
Ähm.
Zusehen und ich, wie gesagt, bin einfach nur erschüttert, dass so, dass es so passiert, ja? Und das eigentlich skandalöse ist, dass der Typ, wie gesagt, nicht rot wird und auch keine Anzeichen macht, dass er abends irgendwie nicht gut schlafen könnte oder so.
Wird sicherlich ein Grund gewesen sein, warum man ihn ausgewählt hat.
Ja gut, der hat ja auch schon seit jeher äh einen entsprechenden Hintergrund, ne? Also das ist jetzt auch war ja jetzt vielleicht auch überraschend gewesen, wenn wenn ausgerechnet so einer äh rauskommt und sagt, ja hier äh.
Ist ein Riesenskandal, also na ja.
Ein paar gute Nachrichten. So ist das nicht.
Paar ist gut eine. Wir haben eine gute Nachricht. Tada!
Einer. Eine gute Nacht. Genau, eine gute Nachricht.
Der Bundestag,
Routerzwang ab. Das ist ein Thema, was wir hier schon längere Zeit behandelt haben, wo es ähm,
immer um die Definition des Netzabschlusspunktes ging,
Die Debatte oder die die Definitionsfrage, wo hört Netz der deutschen Telekom auf und wo fängt dein Wohnzimmer an? Und ähm,
die Provider hätten es natürlich gerne gehabt, dass das Netz dass ihr Netz äh an der Stelle endet, wo also quasi mit dem Plastik der Kiste, die bei dir zu Hause steht und es sieht aber jetzt so aus.
Dass der Netzabschlusspunkt die Dose ist, wo du dieses Gerät reinsteckst und es ist deshalb wichtig, weil durch die Definition des Netzabschlusspunktes quasi der Punkt definiert ist,
Die Schwelle definiert es ab dem ab der man seinen eigenen Kram benutzen kann. Ja und äh,
mit dem neuen Gesetzeslaut dürfen Provider ihre Kunden eben nicht mehr zwingen, bestimmte Hardware zu verwenden für die Einwahl.
Das ist erstmal gut, weil es, wie gesagt, unterschiedliche.
Einschränkungen gibt, die solche Router haben, teilweise im Funktionsumfang, der um dadurch den Nutzer oder die Nutzer zu gängeln, ähm teilweise.
Auch einfach scheiße sind, ja. Also die meisten sind halt Schrott, diese diese dir liefern. Ähm insbesondere, wenn sie von Vodafone oder von der Deutschen Telekom sind oder von Alice,
Wen gibt's noch? Ach Alice heißt gar nicht mehr Alice, ne?
Das ist jetzt alles.
Ja, also es ist alles.
Ist aber eigentlich auch egal, also äh letzten Endes es hat ein bisschen mehr was mit dieser ähm,
Und insofern ist das eben ein ein sehr begrüßenswerte Initiative, ja? Die Frage ist immer so ein bisschen so äh,
Wer ist dein Kunde, wenn wenn dieses Gerät quasi von dem Netzanbieter beauftragt wird? Und ähm,
sozusagen diesen Netzabschlusspunkt definiert, aber eigentlich bezahlt wird die Kiste von dem von dem Telekom Provider.
Dann ist halt dieser Routerhersteller quasi,
ähm also sein Kunde ist der Telekom Provider und nicht derjenige, der dieses Gerät zu Hause dann nutzt für den Netzzugang,
so verhalten sich diese Geräte auch, ja? Also denen es dann irgendwie egal, dass sie sich äh gut bedienen lassen und mit der Security,
geht das dann halt auch nur noch so gut wie eben diesem Telekom-Anbieter, das äh.
Groß kümmert, so und das ist ja dann auch nicht seine Security, sondern das ist ja sind ja nur die Rechner von den Kunden, das betrifft sie ja sozusagen nicht. Und das ist natürlich bei denen,
Unternehmen, die jetzt auch wirklich im Markt sind und die die Kunden selbst ansprechen müssen und die sozusagen sich auch da einen Trackrekord äh verdienen müssen. Die stehen natürlich ganz anders da. Ja, ohne jetzt,
einen da hervorheben zu wollen, aber,
Nur mal als Beispiel, in Deutschland haben wir ja zum Beispiel diese diese Fritzboxen, die sehr verbreitet sind und wir hatten ja davor einem Jahr, gab's ja dann mal so ein größeres Sicherheitsloch,
was zu Recht moniert wurde und,
Die Reaktion von AVM auf dieses Sicherheitsloch war vergleichsweise vorbildlich, weil da wurde halt einfach in so einer Wochenendeaktion erstmal das,
schlimmste irgendwie analysiert, gefixt und ein Generalstabs mäßig Millionen Geräten ein äh Softwareupdate bereitgestellt,
Sowas vermisst man einfach bei allen Anbietern, die dir jetzt sozusagen das Plastik zu Hause abwerfen, von daher ist das schon mal eine ganz sinnvolle Maßnahme hier.
Ja, das vermisst du teilweise über Jahre, ne. Also das äh diese Easy-Boxen oder so, die haben größtenteils heute noch,
Bekannte, Schwachstellen, die die nie jemand gefixt hat. Ja, aber in der entscheidende Punkt war natürlich, warum sie das wollten, war sie wollten dir möglichst irgendwelchen
Einschränkungen, unter Umständen auch noch zu Hause aufböden.
Ja genau, WLAN verkaufen und so.
Genau. Ja, genau. Ja, zahlst du zwei Euro mehr? Hast du auch ein WLAN aufm Klo, ne,
Wirbt ja jetzt sogar O2 mit allerdings, da geht's um Repeater, ja, aber so, ne? Okay, also ist das Ding, weil sie wollten halt auch da irgendwie dir möglichst äh Ärger machen und,
Das ist jetzt aufgelöst, diese diese Option. Wir hatten in Lokbuch Netzpolitik achtzig, glaube ich, die ausführlichen Hintergrunde dieser dieser Debatte Netzabschlusspunkt auch mal auseinandergenommen. Da hatte ich dann auch erklärt, ne, wie das früher war,
da hattest du dann den Splitter
Modem und den Router und jetzt ist das alles ein Gerät und jetzt ist die Frage, ne, wo ist jetzt der Netzabschlusspunkt und so, da hatten wir uns, glaube ich, in LMP achtzig digitaler Klimawandel ausführlich mit auseinandergesetzt,
und begrüßen die ähm Entscheidung des Bundestages. Äh jetzt muss das nochmal durch den,
Bundesrat und.
Der hatte sicher noch zickig gezeigt.
Er hatte sich irgendwie noch zickig gezeigt, aber gleichzeitig ist es nicht
der Bundesrat nicht zustimmungspflichtig, das heißt, er könnte da jetzt irgendwie nochmal mit mit Prüfbitten oder sowas, das nochmal verzögern, aber so eigentlich ist das nichts, womit der Bund, wo der Bundesrat jetzt ernsthaft
nochmal was rumreißen kann. Und das wär dann schon mal sowas, wär dann mal was schönes, ja? Das wir tatsächlich, he he, wir können in seiner eigenen Wohnung, mit unseren eigenen Strom, Steckdosen, unsere eigenen Geräte betreiben. Ist das nicht fein?
Ja, ist super.
Ja, also das ist auch wirklich jetzt nur so eine Kleinigkeit. Ich meine, interessant, dass es jetzt hier mal wirklich der gesamte Bundestag war, also alle Fraktionen ähm dafür gestimmt, für für diese Gesetzesänderung. Das ist ja auch wirklich mal eine eine seltene Einigkeit.
Das könnte man immer häufiger haben.
In die Richtung, ja.
Zumindest, was in die in die Richtung. Ja, ich wollte das auch gerade noch einschränken.
In Großbritannien äh war man sich jetzt auch glaube ich größtenteils einig, ne?
Dann auch alle dafür, weil muss ja mal was gegen den Terrorismus tun. Ist ja ein total großes Problem.
Ja, die Innenministerin, oh das muss, ich weiß, wie wie spricht man Teresa auf Englisch aus?
Ähm.
Ich mach's jetzt nicht.
Glaube auch, Theresa, weil's mit TH geschrieben ist. Äh ich glaube nicht, dass sie jetzt genannt wird, aber sicher sagen, kann ich dir das jetzt nicht.
Ja, also die hat äh vorgestellt eine.
Einen neuen, ein neues Gesetzespaket, das Investor und,
Ähm da wurde dann quasi so, sie spinnen das über ja, also über Telefonie waren wir uns ja die die letzten Jahre immer einig und die letzten Jahrzehnte einig, wie die,
Eingriffmöglichkeiten des Staates in der Telefonie sind.
Und das brauchen wir jetzt auch mal bei Social Media. Und was wir haben wollen, sind Speicher und Entschlüsselungspflichten,
Sagen sie, okay, besuchte Domain-Namen, wollen wir bitte zwölf Monate lang gespeichert haben?
Nicht die tatsächliche Seite, aber die Tomain-Namen, die du besuchst,
ein bisschen technisch wird das interessant, wie sie das hinkriegen wollen.
Ja, weil das eigentlich auf Netzseite nicht nicht zu sehen.
Mehrere Domains sein, also müssten sie irgendwie die DNS-Server anschauen oder so.
Dafür abfragen kommen, dass sie das auch noch.
Du fragst, das wiederum garantiert dir nicht, dass du jede äh jeden Aufruf auch wirklich findest. Also es ist ein bisschen komisch, aber das wundert uns ja nicht, dass sie da jetzt technischen, vielleicht nicht hundertprozentig so, ne?
Ähm und diese genau, das soll zwölf Monate lang,
äh gespeichert werden gleichzeitig, sondern so Telefon und Internetfirmen, die Verbindungsdaten ihrer Kunden speichern. Also, wer, wann, wo, mit wem kommuniziert hat
und damit wollen sie dann eben Licht in äh Strukturen bringen, um zu sehen, welcher Social Media Dienst denn von den Kriminellen genutzt wurde,
Also welche Apps, Messaging-Dienste oder Webseiten, der die, die, die, die Bande, die Terrorbande, äh, benutzt hat oder so, ähm.
Und dann wollen sie gerne.
Aber natürlich ohne richterlichen Beschluss.
Genau, da also genau, diesen Zugriff haben sie ohne richterlichen Beschluss, das ist wichtig. Ähm und das ist, da denkt man sich, ja, wie kommen die denn darauf, ne? Und das ist im Prinzip einfach nur eine nicht genehmigte Speicherpraxis
des GCHQ, die sie quasi damit jetzt nachträglich legalisieren. Das wir erinnern uns.
Ich das erste Mal, ne?
Genau, das war ja immer das Problem der Snowdengeschichte, dass man sich sagt, okay, eine eine dystopische.
Ein histopisches Ergebnis könnte eben sein, dass man überall wo man feststellt, dieses und jenes was wir machen war illegal, dass man das dann eben nicht auf der Machenseite, sondern auf der,
Illegalseite fixt und da hat haben sie sich jetzt hierzu entschieden. Ja, wollen alle alles mögliche speichern, aber.
Das ist echt eine super Methode. So, ach das, ach, das hat gegen das Gesetz verstoßen, da war wohl was falsch am Gesetz. Das Gesetz verstößt gegen die Geheimdienst,
Was haben wir jetzt mal korrigiert? Sorry.
Und dann,
Ähm sagen sie, okay, wir wollen Entschlüsselungsgepflichten für die Provider haben. Das heißt, sie verbieten jetzt nicht Verschlüsselung, aber sie verpflichten die Internetfirmen,
Dechiffrieren verschlüsselter Inhalt zu helfen. Also wenn ein Anbieter dir verschlüsselte, also wenn du die Dienstleistung verschlüsselter Kommunikation bietest, also beispielsweise ähm.
Du hast Mailserver die TLS machen, ja? Dann musst du,
Behilflich sei, diese Verschlüsselung zu brechen. Oder wenn du vielleicht sogar etwas wirklich Verschlüsseltes anbietest, äh vielleicht zum Beispiel nehmen wir doch mal das, nehmen wir jetzt mal hier als als beliebtes Beispiel. Ähm,
da musst du das eben auch auf bei Bedarf knacken. Ne? Auf auf Rückfrage.
Gleichzeitig haben sie ja noch so schöne Sachen drin, Telekommunikationsunternehmen werden verpflichtet, den Geheimdiensten beim Hecken von Computern oder Mobiltelefonen behilflich zu sein,
Das ist dann so dieses schöne Beispiel äh.
Also ähm ich erinnere mich da immer wieder an die Darstellung des dieser Lösung von Gamma für die Installation von Finn Fischer, wo es im Prinzip darum geht, dass das,
Bei den Providersteten gerät im Rack. Ähm das dann auf dich getargetet.
Ähm deine Updates kaputt macht. Also du hast.
Nehmen wir jetzt eben ein Beispiel, dass iTunes, iTunes, auf deinem Windows-Rechner, ja und die wissen halt jetzt, die wollen dich hacken,
Und dann filtern sie erstmal deinen Traffic raus auf Providerebene und sagen, alles klar, den Traffic von dem von diesem Anschluss, den,
Der wird jetzt mal bei uns gesondert, einmal durchgerutet, da sind wir jetzt mal Man in the mittel und dann sagen wir, wenn der das nächste Mal das iTunes,
Ich nehme das jetzt nur als äh theoretisches Beispiel fragt, beim iTunes-Server, gibt es denn hier mal ein Update?
Dann antworten wir mit, aber sicher doch, es gibt ein Update. Ähm hier entlang. Und dann äh gibst du halt ein infiziertes
iTunes raus, ja, was entweder vielleicht tatsächlich die neue Version oder einfach die gleiche, die er schon hat, noch mal. Und bei der Installation dieses iTunes
bastelst du halt deinen Trojaner mit ein auf das System. Ein Beispiel, ja, wo du sagst, okay, du löst das Problem ganz einfach auf Seiten des Providers. Und das kannst du halt super elegant machen, das Ding hast du da stehen,
und dann kannst du dir quasi anhand der Anschlusskennung oder sonst was, die die Ziele raussuchen,
und äh setzt einfach nur dieses System, weil's ja ähm sowieso bei allen Traffic dann einfach Mittel ist
relativ einfach erkennen an dem Browser und so, okay, was haben mit was für ein Betriebssystem haben was da zu tun, was für Software lädt der so runter und dann infizieren wir den einfach mal,
oder du machst andere Scherze und äh baust halt mal irgendwie statt einer Werbung äh irgendwie so ein kleines, unsichtbares äh Flash Explor ein in so eine Seite, wenn ein äh ein unverschlüsselter Seitenaufruf kommt oder so. Also auf auf diese Sachen ziehen sie da ab.
Ähm Zugriff auf die Daten, die sie so sammeln, äh sollen Polizei und Geheimdienste bekommen,
Und sie sagen aber wir erinnern uns äh an an David Camerons erste Rede, wo er dann sagte, so mit mit Unterricht davor behalt und so, ne, Verschlüsselung brechen, darauf zieht es natürlich hier ab. Letztendlich,
Ähm also die Installation von Staatstrojanern wird ja in der Regel damit gerechtfertigt, dass man Verschlüsselungen umgehen muss,
Müsste, will und da sagen sie jetzt, kriegen wir eigens ausgebildete Richter.
Und die werden kontrolliert vom Investor Powers Commissioner jetzt quasi einen eigenen,
Eine eigene Richter, ein eigenes Richterteam spezifisch ausgebildet, das einem Commissioner untersteht.
Nicht, nicht dass wir da jetzt mit normal ausgebildeten Richtern agieren, die auch sonst eigentlich äh die Rechtslage eigentlich ganz gut im Blick haben sollten. Eigentlich äh haben wir ein spezielles Team.
Die gehen nochmal jemand spezielles Team und.
Dann wahrscheinlich, was weiß ich, auch noch dem Innenministerium unterstellt sind oder was weiß.
Und jeder und jeder hat genauso und so Spezialrichter halt, ne? So ein Graulich. Ist ja auch ein Spezial.
Ja, genau. Genau. Den setzt man dann in die Küche und so, ja, hier, also wir haben jetzt hier den Zugriff und so, aber ich habe dir das schon mal geschrieben. Hier hast du noch einen Kaffee.
Ja so. Und dann sagt er aber es ist super geil, sagt er ja und alles immer nur Unterricht davor halt, außer wenn's alt, dann können wir so eine fünftägige Notfallregelung ohne äh gerichterliche Genehmigung.
Sorry, wieder hatten wir jetzt einfach nicht genug Zeit, uns um die Rechtslage zu kümmern, das äh müsst ihr jetzt auch mal verstehen, weil das war ja eilig. Und.
So und David Cameron betrachtet das jetzt als das wichtigste Gesetz dieser Amtsperiode. Das heißt, wir können davon ausgehen, dass er das entschieden vorantreiben wird.
Immerhin ist es nicht mehr der EU-Austritt.
Und die Opposition begrüßt das Gesetz auch, ja, also haben wir genau den Fall, den du dir wünscht, ja.
Alle sind sich einig.
Alle, ne, in großes Bündnis für für das Vereinigte Königreich. Da haben sich aber, machen sich durchaus so ein paar Sorgen um äh Berufsgeheimnisträger, ja?
Kennen wir die Debatte? Und äh internationaler Anbieter, also wie können wie kriegen wir das denn jetzt international unter, ne? Was machen wir mit Apple?
Ja, weil weil David Cameron will uns jetzt unsere iPhones wegnehmen, was im Prinzip die Botschaft dieses dieses Gesetzes.
Muss man vielleicht noch kurz dazu sagen, also äh sind Ende zu Ende verschlüsselt, aber Apple hat natürlich die Möglichkeit,
Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung kaputt zu machen, indem sie einfach ein weiteres Gerät anmelden. Aber was man Apple an der Stelle eben zu Gute halten muss, ist, dass sie,
Immerhin,
die Massenüberwachung dadurch unmöglich machen. Ja, also man kann gezielt eine kann Apple halt quasi dir einfach noch ein Device unterjubeln, ohne es dir zu sagen,
Das wäre dann eben, würde dann der Polizei gehören. Ähm und,
Also wer, wer in der äh undankbaren Situation es mehrere ID Vices zu haben oder einen Computer und ein ein hier so ein Apple Computer und ein iPhone wenn man dann sagt, okay, man registriert diese
Geräte jetzt, dann kriegt man ja eine Mail. Wird gesagt so, du hast ein neues äh Device, deinem Ei-Message zugefügt und das empfängt jetzt auch deine Nachrichten,
So und was Apple jetzt als Angriff machen würde auf diese Verschlüsselung ist, die einfach noch ein Gerät dazu fügen,
ohne es dir zu sagen. So insofern ist App.
Sagen nicht, dass sie das jetzt wir sagen nicht, dass Apple das so vor hat zu tun, sondern das wäre nur eine technische Möglichkeit, das im Rahmen der derzeit äh vorliegenden Verschlüsselungstechnik zu realisieren.
Ich ähm ich gehe davon aus, dass es eine öffentliche Quelle dazu gibt.
Wenn nicht, dann bitte ich das an dieser Stelle zu entschuldigen. Aber es gibt der Tim Kuck hat, glaube ich, auch öffentlicher gesagt, dass was ihre Richtlinien sind für den Zugriff. Und hat da auch im Prinzip implizit,
angesagt, dass es einen Zugriff auf iMessage und Facetime gibt. Also insofern wird Apple da jetzt nicht so ein großes Problem bekommen,
Ähm,
Genau, im Frühling zwanzig sechzehn wollen sie ihre Beratung über den Wurf abgeschlossen haben, damit das dann mal flott in die Verabschiedung gehen kann. Also Großbritannien herzlichen Glückwunsch, so David Cameron, ganz großes Kino,
macht euch da jetzt halt irgendwie das, worüber sich vielleicht noch ein paar von euch eventuell mal geärgert haben. Das wird jetzt einfach nachlegalisiert und ähm die,
eure Telefonanbieter werden dazu verpflichtet, der Regierung dabei zu helfen, euch zu hacken. Zwölf Monate lang alles zu speichern.
Ja gut, aber für welche Unternehmen sollte das gelten?
Das ist der äh Einwand der Opposition, weil sie eben nicht wissen, wie sie das bei internationalen Anbietern erzwingen können.
Ja, du wirst dich nämlich jetzt auch nicht, um ehrlich zu sein. Ich meine, alle, alle, die jetzt dann äh äh einen Laden da haben, die fallen natürlich irgendwie schon unter diese Regelung. Das ist ein bisschen was anderes.
Also äh wir wissen ja, dass äh Großbritannien diese schönen Pornofilter hat, äh an denen David Cameron ja auch sehr hängt,
wir hatten das letzte Woche oder in der letzten Sendung gar nicht erwähnt, aber als er dann von der,
Netzneutralitätsregulation hörte, die wir ja alle so oder die wir hier sehr scharf kritisiert haben, äh die hat David Cameron auch stark kritisiert, weil sie hat gemacht, dass er seine Müslis ausspucken, sein Müsli morgens ausspucken musste.
Äh ja.
Hat er ungefähr, also war doch so, ne? Also seine Formulierung war irgendwie so mein meine Cornflakes äh sind. Ich habe meine Cornflakes in der Küche verteilt oder sowas. Also,
Der Deutsche sagt, ich kotze ins Essen, so das hat er irgendwie, das ist dem David Cameron passiert, weil seine Pornfilter von dieser,
Von dieser idiotischen Netznetralität jetzt bedroht sind. Und insofern war das ja Porn-und Terrorismusfilter sind
wäre ich jetzt nicht mehr verwundert, wenn der dieses Problem internationaler Anbieter einfach über seine Porno-und Terrorismus sperren,
Unter Umständen androhen würde zu lösen. Aber ich will bin auch nicht dafür da, denen jetzt noch eine Lösung für die Scheiße zu suchen, ja?
Also das Problem, so das haben sie jetzt davor, wir dürfen das mit,
mit Spannung beobachten, was was die Briten sich da jetzt noch einfallen lassen äh um ihren Clusterfaktor nochmal ein bisschen äh zu verfeinern.
Ja, vor allem frage ich mich gerade, was eigentlich diese ganzen Formen, diese Gesetzesformen,
wird sicherlich nicht lange dauern bis Ungarn da in dem Bereich auch nochmal kräftig nachlegt, wenn's nicht schon längst getan haben oder sich eigentlich um Gesetze sowieso nicht groß äh äh kümmern,
Frage ist natürlich so, was ist auf EU-Ebene eigentlich zulässig in dieser Hinsicht? Und.
Das ist mit Sicherheit noch nicht irgendwie,
griffig geregelt, auch wenn natürlich das, was hier ähm beschlossen wird, wenn ich das richtig sehe, ja, Prinzip so eine Art verschärfte Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist.
Also ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen, dass wir demnächst auch auf europäischer Ebene.
Dann nochmal so einen neuen Track kriegen, der versucht eben auch diese ganzen Maßnahmen zu legalisieren.
Und ja, keine Ahnung. Haben wir zumindest noch mal ein bisschen was zum Heulen nächstes Jahr.
Ja, tolle Aussicht, Tim, danke. Ah, jetzt kommen wir zu meinem Lieblingsthema heute. Ja, jetzt kommen wir zu meinem Lieblingsthema. Tim, was hast du denn, was haben wir denn da Schönes stehen? Hast du dir was schönes Neues von Apple gekauf.
Ja, ganz toll, voll die Zukunft und so. Hm.
Zukunft? Fernsehen mit dem man sprechen kann, ne? Genau. Geil.
Genau. Ja, ja, die App-Store.
Weißt du was, was schön wäre? Da könnte man ja, da könnte man ja jetzt ähm CCC-Kongressvideos draufgucken. Wäre geil, ne? Ja, habe ich auch gedacht.
Das wäre geil, oder? Ja, dachte ich mir auch. Dachte sich auch, äh Chris.
Hat Chris aus Offenbach,
Besser bekannt als Peter Dansten Jean, geht hin und macht, das muss man sich mal vorstellen, ist doch toll. Baut eine,
oder der CCC äh Frankfurt Main war das, glaube ich, ne, den in dessen Namen wurde da eine App gebastelt für das Apple TV. Das Apple TV ist ja jetzt äh,
Der neueste Schrei aus dem Hause Apple mit so einer also des Apple.
TV gibt's schon länger, aber es gibt eine neue Version, die,
auch einen App Store äh hat und damit sozusagen genauso das einreichen von äh Apps ermöglicht oder eben auch nicht ermöglicht, ähm wie man das vom von iOS her kennt und der Prozess ist auch sehr vergleichbar
Insofern als dass man da eben dann der Begutachtung des App Store Review Teams und ihren Guidelines unterliegt,
und äh Chris hat halt eine App geschrieben, die im Übrigen nichts Besonderes äh ist in technischer Hinsicht, da sie sich auch einfach nur an,
der empfohlenen Art und Weise, wie man so eine einfache App strickt,
orientiert, da gibt's so ein XML und und Java Skript, Clim Bim, mit dem man so typische, ich präsentiere mal Videos auf dieser Plattform, aus einem,
Selektionskreis. Ähm wie man das eben äh leicht bauen kann. Von daher war sozusagen,
diese App jetzt ähm,
auch noch nicht jetzt mit sonderlicher Komplexität ausgestattet, wo es schwierig gewesen wäre, die zu bewerten durch einen App Store Team. Trotzdem gab es eine Ablehnung, nachdem diese App eingereicht wurde.
Ganz kurz noch zur Funktionalität der App, denn die App war im Prinzip ein,
Ein vereinfachter, ein vereinfachter Zugriff, ein Frontend auf Media CCC DE, wo das äh CCC Wok, das Voice, äh das Off-Voice. Video Operation Center, ähm.
Aller allerlei Aufzeichnungen von,
Veranstaltungen publiziert. Insbesondere natürlich den CCC-Kongress, aber auch andere Konferenzen wie Chaos Cologne, Datenspuren, ähm Fiffcon, also was weiß.
Und überhaupt so das ganze ganze Archiv eigentlich auch aus früheren Jahren, wo es das Wok jetzt in der Form noch gar nicht äh gab, also das ist sozusagen einfach der Ort, wo der CCC-Content ist und
Natürlich ist das eine gute Idee, darauf so ein gezielten Zugriff zu bringen.
Finde ich super geil. Hätte ich auch also genau das hätte ich gerne, weil bis bisher hat man dann höchstens mal ähm ja so als als RSS-Feed alles gehabt, eine Veranstaltung oder so, dann konntest du im Prinzip dir den
den Kongress in in deinen Podcast reinballern oder sowas, ne? Aber.
So das wäre, muss ich echt sagen, für mich ein Grund gewesen, mir diesen Kiss, diese Kiste da zu kaufen und zu sagen, okay, die steht da zu Hause und dann habe ich die,
Media CCC DE App, da die hoffentlich, ich hab's jetzt,
in der Malung eines solchen Gerätes auch noch nicht ausprobieren können, wo ich dann einfach sagen kann, okay, random, gib mir ein random Kongressvortrag und lass den mal einfach so da laufen. Wer ist halt richtig cool?
Äh ich kann dich insofern beruhigen, du wirst äh diese Qualität auch äh haben
weil die Videos, die hier angeboten werden, sind ja verfügbar auf der Apple TV, nur eben nicht durch diese App, die äh der Chris geschrieben hat, weil die App ist halt abgelehnt worden wegen bestimmter Videos auf Media CCC DE, das Absurde ist nur, dass diese Videos eben sehr wohl
vorliegen, auch auf YouTube und die YouTube-App wird sie äh dir auch weiterhin vorspielen. Vielleicht nochmal kurz zu dem Prozess. Also, die App wurde geschrieben,
Wurde eingereicht,
Letzte Woche ist der Appstore live gegangen und es gab dann eben eine Ablehnung und diese Ableitlehnung wurde halt begründet. Ähm äh dadurch, dass eben,
Diese App angeblich gegen das äh Apple Developer Program Liverement verstoßen würde. Konkret die Sektion drei zwo,
Wo es äh heißt, ähm Apple Software et cetera ähm.
Also jetzt wollte ich's gerade zusammenfassen, ist mir äh komplett misslungen. Ich fange einfach nochmal an. Ähm also es wurde darauf äh,
hingewiesen, dass diese Bedingungen besagen, dass man eben kein Programm abliefern darf, was in irgendeiner Form,
die also sozusagen gegen die Sicherheitslösung des Systems äh vorgeht, ja, hier wird auch wirklich das Wort Hack benutzt,
Security Digital Signing Digital Rights Management,
et cetera. Ähm also diese,
Dieser Absatz sagt halt, ein Programm darf eben kein Werkzeug sein, was irgendwie selbst gegen die Sicherheitsmechanismen des Betriebssystems vorgeht,
oder andere anders äh in die Lage versetzen, so etwas vorzunehmen.
Dieser Absatz klingt für mich danach ähm.
Darauf abzuzielen, dass man nicht eine ähm,
in den App Store bringen kann. Ja, du sagst also hier, was wird Download jellbreak und äh die würde das heißt, diese App würde,
Eingreifen in das Sicherheitskonzept des äh Systems oder anderen dabei helfen, dies zu tun. Also kannst auch keine J-Brake-App äh anbieten, die,
nur erklärt, wie's geht. Und äh offenbar hat einer von diesen App-Store das ein bisschen zu ernst genommen.
Oder falsch interpretiert, ne?
Na ja, was sie dann halt moniert haben, ist, dass man eben durch diese App auf Media CCC DE Vorträge finden kann, die sich eben sehr wohl mit J-Braking auseinandersetzen. Also wir hatten ja vor ein paar Jahren hier auch so diese äh Garde der frühen J-Breaker
hier so und so weiter auf der Bühne in Berlin es gab halt insgesamt glaube ich fünf monierte Talks.
Nee, sind mehr. Acht.
Mehr noch? Acht? Okay.
Und die haben also da ist auch einer mit dabei, aber der ist irgendwie Hardware-Tex ähm ähm Bluetooth Hacking,
Hacking, Medical Devices, ich weiß nicht, ob die jetzt meinen, dass ihr Fernsehgerät, der jetzt auch ein Medical-Device wäre. Game Hacking and Reverse Engineering, ja, auch,
noch eher kein besonders naher Bezug zu diesem Apple TV. Crypto Hacking Exports,
Also ja, aus dem Bereich ähm.
Der Politik auch eine Einführung? Und Industriespionage,
Also und äh Apps. Also äh also ernsthaft Tim.
Panebüchen. Äh Erläuterung und vor allem wurde das natürlich jetzt ähm dann entsprechend von einem Chris äh,
beklagt dieses Urteil, weil es ja nun, wie es schon sagte, so ist, dass diese Videos,
Frei im Internet stehen, unter anderem bei YouTube und die YouTube-App ja auch nicht abgelehnt wird, weil diese Inhalte vorhanden sind.
Apple dann irgendwie sich sogar wohl telefonisch gemeldet hat und das irgendwie nochmal erläutert hat, weil ja diese App
würde sich ja primär auf Hacking beziehen und von daher wäre es ja sozusagen äh Fokus, solche Inhalte in den Vordergrund zu stellen und das wäre bei YouTube ja nicht der Fall und deswegen würde das ja für YouTube nicht gelten.
Also ich weiß gar nicht, was ich dazu sagen soll. Das ist wirklich problematisch,
Also erstmal finde ich das schon mal problematisch, dass man hier keinen Unterschied macht zwischen einer App, die ähm,
Wie du schon vorhin äh ausgeführt hast, explizit zum Umgehen einer Sicherheitslösung des Geräts gedacht ist, ja? Ähm sondern technisch diese App ja sozusagen einfach nur Inhalte vermittelt.
Die die hat ja sogar noch ein, sie hat ja noch einen ganz anderen, viel wichtigeren, also diese App. Diese Videos, ja, wenn du beim CCC-Kongress die Öffentlichkeit über,
Sicherheitsprobleme informierst oder auch von mir aus eine Anleitung.
Gibst, wie man ein Sicherheitsproblem findet.
Vielleicht auch ein nicht benanntes, wo du sagst, okay, Reverse-Engineering geht so.
Ist einfach Bildung.
Dann ist das Bildung und der Effekt dieser Videos, dieser Vorträge und dieser Veranstaltung ist, dass die Systeme, die dort behandelt werden in der Konsequenz sicherer werden,
Die Veröffentlichung von Wissen über IT-Sicherheit steigt die IT-Sicherheit. Sie sinkt nicht, sondern sie steigt. Dadurch, dass jemand hingeht und ein veröffentlicht oder,
mehr Leute äh mehr Leuten das Wissen gibt einen zu finden.
Dadurch werden mehr gefunden. Diese werden beseitigt. Ja, jeder, der irgendwie öffentlich geworden ist, wurde von Apple innerhalb von,
relativ kurzer Zeit ähm quasi ähm beseitigt, ja. Das Schlimme sind die J-Breaks, die,
die nicht öffentlich sind
wie übrigens jetzt gerade diese ähm diese Startup oder diese neue Bude, die irgendwie mit handeln will, die jetzt grade ein iOS-Gabreck für eine Millionen gekauft haben, ne? Das war ja eher ein Stunt, also der ich glaube nicht, dass der Markt,
der restliche Markt tatsächlich bereit ist, eine Million für einen zu geben, aber um sich mal einfach überall ins Gespräch zu bringen, als die Bude, die dir deine Zero Days abkauft, war das sicherlich eine sinnvoll investierte Million. Ja? Ähm,
Diese Vorträge sind teilweise auch alt,
Ja und man hat hier den Eindruck äh als jemand, der, wie ich das Kongressprogramm durchaus nochmal ein bisschen ähm.
Besser kennt als offenbar dieser Appstore äh,
Vertreter ähm ist diese Auswahl an Talks, sage ich mal, nicht nicht besonders erschöpfend,
oder äh bis nach dem die lässt keine, keine profunde Kenntnis des Programms, ähm.
Überhaupt nicht. Ich meine, wenn sie
wenn sie sich überhaupt dann damit mehr auseinandergesetzt hätten, äh ich meine, wie du schon sagst, mit der Bildung, ne? Also, ich meine, wir hatten ja auch mal äh hier so Personen wie äh
Windows Neider äh auf dem Kongress mehrfach äh zu Gast, die sich dort sozusagen vom Inhalt hat berieseln lassen, die es dann halt später.
Apple gegangen und hat dort halt äh als Security-Personen gearbeitet und zwar ein leitender äh Stelle,
Und das, das ist halt das, was man aufm Kongress mitnehmen kann. Ich denke, also ich weiß es nicht. Wir haben's hier auch noch mit dem App Store Team zu tun.
Ja, das muss man jetzt auch mal äh beleuchten an der Stelle. Ähm.
Was ich damit sagen will ist, es gibt sicherlich noch einen Weg, den man hier beschreiten kann, so,
Sollte man sicherlich auf jeden Fall nochmal thematisieren, auch wenn man jetzt sich,
zu sehr darauf äh ähm festlegen sollte, dass es jetzt unbedingt diese App geben muss, weil die Inhalte ja trotzdem erreichbar. Auf der anderen Seite ist das natürlich schon auch ein eine Form von
Zensur, die hier ausgeübt wird so in so einem Eigeninteresse.
Du hattest dann, also genau, kommen wir mal jetzt. Wir haben jetzt lange genug da, um den heißen Brei herumgeredet. Apple geht hin und sagt, okay, diese Inhalte nicht auf unserer Plattform, die missfallen uns.
So, es gibt vielleicht andere Wege so, aber das es andere Wege gibt, heißt nicht, dass man sich hinsetzt und sagt, hey, hey, wir können jetzt trotzdem das gucken. Nein, das heißt, dass Apple hier konkret,
den CCC im Wald gefasst beziehungsweise seine Vortragenden daran hindert, auf diese Plattform zu kommen.
Gleichberechtigt auf die Plattform zu kommen, wie alle anderen Inhalte auch. Mhm.
Genau, wie alle anderen. So und das ist absolut nicht zu akzeptieren.
Und das sollte man sich sehr genau merken, denn nicht alle Inhalte, Anbieter oder.
Oder.
Leute, die ähm Apps für diese Systeme bauen, haben die Möglichkeit, ähm sich so viel.
Öffentlichkeit für so ein Thema zu zu generieren, wie jetzt ein Vertreter des CCC
ja, der in Videos von einer Konferenz zeigt, die äh jährlich mehr mehr als zehntausend Besucher äh empfängt,
ja, die durchaus internationale,
signifikant in diesem Themenbereich hat, ja, wo wir, glaube ich, alle sehr stolz drauf sind. Und,
Das ist genau das, also ich das ist genau das, vor dem wir die ganze Zeit warnen, ja? Das ist die das Paradebeispiel von,
Wir gehen immer hin und sagen, passt auf, dass euch die Geräte selber gehören
passt auf, dass ihr mit diesen scheiß äh World Garden Ökosystemen, in die ihr euch da begebt. So, ich meine, diese ganze Apple Nummer ist irgendwie schön und gut, aber ne, beachtet mal irgendwie
ne, halt in was für eine komische Lage ihr euch da begebt, ja? Und.
Jetzt muss ich hier noch kurz Klammer auf sagen. Ich meine, diese die Android-Situation ist jetzt auch nicht unbedingt eine
eine Parade, Beispielalternative, bevor wir uns jetzt hier die die Android äh Apologeten einfangen, äh weil da einfach das gesamte Betriebssystem, dieses gesamte App-Konzept einfach vollständig für den Arsch ist und das halt irgendwie
Statistiken, die irgendwie ungefähr so sind, so achtzig Prozent der Androidgeräte, die da draußen rumfliegen haben
Bekannte Sicherheitslücken, ja, die die Hersteller dieser Geräte sich noch nicht mal mehr anschicken, zu fixen. Also das ist, kannst du jetzt nicht irgendwie als eine als eine ernstzunehmende Alternative sehen
Und abgesehen davon hast du das Gleiche bei Android ja auch, dass der Google Play Store ähm,
Selbstverständlich auch eine Auswahl der Inhalte trifft und nicht einfach alles zulässt, oder? Da gibt's auch ein Review-Prozess. Ist zumindest meine Erfahrung von den zwei Android Apps, die ich da mal reingeschoben habe.
Es gibt einen Review-Prozess, der äh erst später auch ähm,
andere Beine gestellt wurde, also am Anfang hat man das noch sehr lachs äh gehandhabt, dann hat man halt festgestellt, dass man irgendwie den ganzen Store voll mit äh hatte. Das hat man wahrscheinlich jetzt auch immer noch, aber man hatte zumindest eben versucht, ein paar Regeln
durchzuziehen. Mir ist jetzt kein Fall bekannt, wo jetzt vergleichbar mit diesem Fall ähm jetzt wirklich so über Inhalte,
etwas gesperrt worden wäre, aber da habe ich auch wirklich keinen guten äh Überblick. Das ist auch schon, würde ich sagen, eine eine spezifische Geschichte bei bei Apple,
die hier einfach auch,
Ähm über den Appstore verschiedene Sachen versuchen zu steuern. Das eine ist natürlich das wo ich auch größtmögliches Verständnis habe,
Einfach was die ganze Security der User betrifft, ja?
Es ist klar, also es ist sagen wir mal begrüßenswert, wenn ein ähm,
Provider in irgendeiner Form Checks hat,
zu verhindern oder zumindest stark zu reduzieren, dass ich mir Software eintrete, die für mich vom Nachteil ist. So, das finde ich einen begrüßenswerte Eigenschaft. Die andere Sache, die Apple aber darüber steuert, ist die Wahrnehmung ihrer Produkte,
In so einer Marketingperspektive passt das zu uns. Ja, wie viele Purz-Apps äh dürfen wir in unserem äh Store haben,
bevor das sozusagen auf uns zurückfällt. Und hier merkt man natürlich auch wieder so ein Rift zwischen,
Europa oder spezifisch auch deutscher ähm deutschem Selbstverständnis was Hacking Kultur betrifft,
und der Sichtweise in USA, die sich vielleicht stellenweise auch ein bisschen geändert äh haben mag, ja, aber in dieser Ablehnung ist ja auch die Formulierung drin.
Content related to you breaking, ah Hacking, Apple Devices ist not ecceptible in your äh App. Ähm,
und die App sei jetzt, finde ich, die Formulierung doch wieder nicht, also im Wesentlichen stören sie sich da dran, dass es eben hier About Hacking ist.
Und das, das, das äh zeigt, glaube ich, auch einfach schon mal da diese äh positive äh Dissonanz, dass das einfach es als etwas Schlechtes angesehen wird,
Sich mit solchen Themen zu beschäftigen, zumindest wenn dann eben auch noch das Wort Jähbrecht drin vorkommt.
Ja, aber es geht nicht nur, also ich, das Entscheidende an diesem Fall ist doch, nicht, dass es jetzt irgendwie grade mal,
in diesem Fall den CCC getroffen hat und dass dass Apple irgendwie äh ein gestörtes Verhältnis zu Security an dieser Stelle zeigt, in Form von diesem einen App Store Review, das Entscheidende ist eigentlich, dass sie überhaupt,
Ist offenbar für vertretbar halten,
Eine derartige Form der Inhaltskontrolle zu haben. Ich will mich überhaupt nicht auf die Debatte einlassen, diese Inhalte irgendwie äh zu verteidigen.
Weißt, da muss ich jetzt nicht lange irgendwie sagen, ha, Apple hat eine äh hat eine äh komische Verständnis von IT-Sicherheit oder das falsche Verhältnis zum Hacking. Nee, die haben das falsche Verhältnis zu ihrer gesamten scheiß
Ökosystem, was sie da haben. So, das das geht so nicht, dass sie irgendwie in dieser Form, in dieser ähm.
Tiefe ihre äh ihre eigenen Interessen auf dieser Plattform in in Form eines solchen Eingriffs da meinen zu wahren. Und,
Das Schöne daran ist oder das Spannende an diesem Fall ist, die haben alles Recht der Welt dazu und es gibt überhaupt gar keinen Grund, sich jetzt zu beklagen.
Ja, wir können also ich meine, das ist jedem ist jedem klar und sollte jedem klar sein, der sich solche Geräte kauft,
Alles, was auf diesem Gerät stattfindet, ist Apple.
Die ähm die Community, die für diese Geräte existiert, ähm macht,
Sicherlich gerade äh angenehmes Geld, aber sie sind im Prinzip.
Nur Product Plugins.
Genau, sie sind im Prinzip nur Plugins, ja? Du musst ja, glaube ich, ich weiß nicht, was ist da die Policy? Du gibst ein Drittel deiner ähm.
Dreißig Prozent.
Ja, ist ja ungefähr ein ja, knappes, gibt's ein knappes Drittel deiner Umsätze. Gehen bleiben einfach direkt bei Apple. Dafür kommst du für einen Huni im Jahr oder was äh kriegst du eine Zulassung.
Für alle Stores.
Als die als Developer für alle Stores. So, wir kommen aus einer Welt, wo man einfach mal Computer programmieren konnte, wie man will
ja? Da konnte jeder zu Hause sein Computer programmieren
und konnte diese äh Programme dann öffentlich zur Verfügung stellen. Und das gibt keinen Anlass, äh warum das nicht immer schon so hätte sein sollen, äh warum das nicht auch einfach so hätte bleiben sollen, ja, es gibt ja auch Ökosysteme, äh wie jetzt irgendwie unterschiedlichen Dealungsdistrozonen, in denen das auch noch genauso ist,
Ja, ähm aber Apple geht halt hin und baut diese komischen Plattformen.
In denen es eine etwas unselige Mischung aus der Hardware, die sie dir verkaufen und dem, was du damit tun kannst, gibt.
Und wie gesagt, ich gehöre nicht zu denen, die jetzt sagen, okay, das ist jetzt ähm.
Besonderer Skandal, so das haben wir alle gewusst, als wir, was weiß ich, uns als Developer für Apple registriert haben, das haben wir alle gewusst, als wir uns diese Geräte gekauft haben und,
Es gibt leider keinerlei Handhabe dagegen Apple. Man kann aus unserer Perspektive jetzt nur zeigen so,
Schaut euch das an, merkt euch das und überlegt euch, wie viele Funktionen ihr unter Umständen auf den Geräten nicht habt, wie viele App es nicht gibt,
aufgrund der Interessen dieses Unternehmens. Und das geht ja auch noch weiter. Ich meine, ähm,
Apple ist da jetzt auch nicht der einzige äh Konzern, der äh in der Form seine,
Interessenmind wahrnehmen zu müssen, ne. Wir haben vor kurzem die Meldung gehabt, dass Amazon ähm aufhört, diese Apple-TVs zu verkaufen.
Ja, das heißt, dieser ganze Gate-Keeper-Funktion.
Vor der wir immer gewarnt haben, bei großen Konzernen, bei großen Monokulturen, bei großen Ökosystemen, in die wir uns begeben.
Die wird jetzt auch zusehends immer weit immer wieder ausgenutzt von den Konzernen.
Ja, also, wie gesagt, Amazon entscheidet sich Produkthits. Konkurrenzprodukte zu ihren eigenen nicht mehr zu verkaufen, weil sie wissen, dass sie in großen signifikanten Anteil am Retail haben und dass sie da anderen weh tun können,
Google mag sich entscheiden,
Bestimmte Suchergebnisse von der Konkurrenz. Selbstverständlich, wenn du auf Google nach Maps suchst, ist der erste Treffer. Google Maps, alles andere wäre auch Unsinn, ist auch klar, ne? Und Big Maps steht sicherlich auch noch irgendwo da drin,
Ich bin mal gespannt, wenn jetzt wenn die jetzt immer weiter mit diesen Plattformen kämpfen, fortfahren.
Dann wird sich das immer mehr offenbaren, wie diese auch diese schönen Hardwarehersteller von den tollen iPhones oder so, dass die halt alle,
bereit sind, ihre Macht, die sie erlangt haben für ihre finanziellen oder auch sonstigen kruden Interessen zu nutzen,
Und wie gesagt, wir können da jetzt
dann ja auch Debatten, ne, dann wurde er halt in diesem Zusammenhang der Begriff der Zensur genutzt und dann äh hast du immer, wenn du wenn irgendjemand Zensur sagt, hast du immer auch irgendjemand, der sagt, ah, du hast doch gar keine Ahnung, was richtige
Suhr ist in China, das ist Zensur, aber das ist hier äh Apple, das ist ja kein staatlicher Akteur. Ja, das sind alles äh da kann man sich dann im Detail über die Begriffe streiten. Aber.
Ich bin, wie gesagt, der ich liege bei der Ansicht, dass Apple das selbstverständlich darf. Das haben wir alle unterschrieben. Und das wussten wir auch alle, als wir den Mist gekauft haben.
Aber ähm.
Es ist wirklich sehr ähm besorgniserregend einfach, äh das in dieser Form zu sehen.
Also ich sehe da durchaus noch Regulationsbedarf in der Zukunft, weil,
Natürlich auf der einen Seite, zumindest derzeit oder bisher zumindest, ähm das Argument sticht, naja, ist ja ihr Produkt, da können sie machen, was sie wollen, ja? Nur ist es halt so, die Realität zeigt,
diese Produkte sind halt mittlerweile nicht nur einfach nur Produkte, die an einem Markt teilnehmen, diese Produkte sind Markt.
Und nirgendswo zeigt sich das halt so stark wie bei äh,
den App Stores von äh Apple. Die Umsätze, die da gefahren werden, da werden einige äh Länder auf diesem Planeten äh ganz glücklich, wenn sie irgendwie so ein Bruttoinlandsprodukt äh aufweisen könnten.
Und in zunehmenden Maße ist eben die Teilnahme an diesem Markt für ein Unternehmen.
Absolut essentiell. Du kannst einfach dein Businessmodell unter Umständen überhaupt nicht mehr bringen, wenn du nicht auch,
gleichberechtigt an diesem Markt teilnehmen kannst. Wenn aber in diesem Markt die Interessen von Apple,
in irgendeiner Form mit deinem Produkt äh im Konflikt stehen. Und selbst wenn sie nur meinen, dass das so ist und das vielleicht gar nicht,
offensichtlich so ist, ja?
Dann hast du kein Produkt mehr.
Dann hast du kein Produkt und dann hast du keinen Zugang zu diesem Markt und an der Stelle ist halt einfach dieser schöne Traum vom vom freien Markt her. Ne, ohnehin debattierungswürdig ist, aber äh ausgeträumt. Und das zeigt sich für meinen Geschmack,
partiell sicherlich auch in diesem Fall, auch wenn es, sagen wir mal, jetzt wirklich nur ein äh Nebenkriegsschauplatz äh ist in dieser Diskussion, sehr stark zeigt es sich aber zum Beispiel im Bereich,
Payment,
und derzeit ne, sieht man die Vorstöße äh den den Zahlungsmarkt zu kontrollieren oder zumindest signifikant mitzuspielen,
Wird dann noch allerlei Verdrängungswettbewerb ähm auslösen.
Er passt nicht, passt nicht zu deren äh und.
Ja, nee, aber ich meine, will jetzt nicht die alte Leier rausholen, aber so flatter und so weiter, solche Payments-Systeme sind halt da einfach äh äh stark reglementiert, die äh widersprechen halt sozusagen der Marktlogik
innerhalb dieses äh äh Marktes von Apple und verhindern halt einfach entsprechende Durchbrüche und es wird jetzt nicht mehr lange dauern und es werden halt auch Banken und so weiter daran zerschellen.
Und dann bin ich mal gespannt, wie die Antwort sein wird auf ähm zum Beispiel auf EU-Ebene.
Also genau, das Ruf, es, es, es ruft nach ähm irgendwelchen Kartellrechtlichen äh Zähmungen, was was da passiert.
Absolut. Absolut. Jetzt gibt's erstmal von uns gibt's jetzt erstmal Medienzähmung.
Wer trotzdem diese App installieren möchte, kann das aber auch äh tun mit ein bisschen Hackeraufwand,
legt man sich einfach den South Code und installiert sich das einfach mit seiner eigenen Apple-Idee, die selber auf seinem Gerät, das ist natürlich jetzt nicht so schön bunt, die klicki und einfach und mal eben, aber geht.
Kostet nur, was kostet so ein Fernseher hier? Fernsehding. Zweihundert Euro oder.
Das Device.
Ja, kann man sich auch einfach sparen.
Ja, kann man sich auch im Browser angucken, klar. Aber geht halt auch.
Ich hätte das, ich hätte das Ding wahrscheinlich echt gekauft, aber äh man muss auch mal so diese Hilflosigkeit sehen, ne, weil ja ähm,
Jetzt muss der CCC zum zum Apple Boycord aufrufen, ne, oder jetzt dürfen wir alle diesen dieses Ding nicht kaufen, ich kauf's tatsächlich nicht, aber ähm.
Ja, so, ich meine, war von vorneherein klar, als man den Develope-Account gemacht hat. War von vorneherein klar,
Als man das Ding gekauft hat, so und im Prinzip, ja, ich meine, gut, die die App war wahrscheinlich eh kostenlos, hätte kein Geld äh gekostet, aber wenn, dann hätte man am Ende eh nur Nummern äh,
dreißig Prozent der Umsetzer an Apple abgeben müssen. Also es ist wirklich nicht besonders schön.
Noch was, was nicht besonders schön ist, Tim.
Ja noch, wir haben noch ein paar nicht so schöne Sachen.
Wirklich.
Ja. Der Bundesrat hat jetzt die Vorratsdatenspeicherung in ihrer Form ähm nicht großartig,
Diskussionswürdig gefunden und hat das also quasi äh durchgewunken und ähm,
einige Bundestagsabgeordnete um Tabea Rößner und die mehreren, also diese ganzen, was ich auch schon angekündigt hat oder was sie auch schon angekündigt hatten, Medien, Journalistenverbände und so äh haben also jetzt,
ähm angekündigt, dagegen vorzugehen und,
Bundestagsabgeordneten um Tabea Rößner gehen, beantragten beim Bundesverfassungsgericht eine einstweilige Anordnung um das Gesetz direkt zu kippen. Ähm da muss ich jetzt dazu sagen, ich weiß nicht genau,
Wie das rechtlich zu bewerten ist, was ist also eine einstweilige Anordnung des Bundesverfassungsgerichts? Es klingt für mich so ein bisschen so als.
Hätte so unmittelbare Verhinderungspotential.
Genau, das heißt, da könnte das also wenn ich das nehmen wir mal, also es klingt für mich danach, als könnte hier wäre das ein Rechtsmittel, um quasi ein Gesetz schon,
einstweilig, ja?
Sofort zu verhinder.
Ähm zu verhindern und.
Die Einführung, die Einführung zu verhindern, bis eine weitere Klärung erfolgt ist.
Genau, bis eine weiter, also wir wir kennen die einstweiligen Verfügung, wo das Gericht also quasi sagt, wegen Gefahr,
machen wir hier quasi ein Schnellurteil und dann kannst du dich natürlich gegen die einstweilige Verfügung zur Wehr setzen und dann wird äh verhandelt, ja, aber bis dahin gilt die einstweilige Verfügung. Und das scheint das zu sein, was hier jetzt von,
Tabea Rößner angestrengt wird, dass sie sagt, okay erstmal eine einstweilige Verfügung gegen dieses Gesetz, äh eine einstweilige Anordnung gegen dieses Gesetz und dann äh direkt aushandeln auf das ähm die geforderten,
Praktiken gar nicht erst Einzug erhalten, ähm um und dann irgendwie bis zum, bis zum Verhandlung, bis zum Abschluss der Verhandlung vielleicht schon längst aufgebaut wird, ja. Das heißt, sie wollen nicht, dass diese äh Speicherpflicht
bis zu der Entscheidung des Verfassungsgerichtes überhaupt erstmal gültig wird, werden wir sehen, welchen Erfolg sie,
Damit haben werden, dann gibt's natürlich auch noch die anderen, die diese Verfassungsklage anstrengen. Da überschlagen sich natürlich jetzt auch alle ähm,
diese äh gegen dieses Gesetz vorzugehen. Spannend finde ich aber, dass doch.
Ja, ach, vielleicht auch nicht.
Was findest du spannend? Findst du nicht spannend.
Nee, finde ich nicht spannend finde. Nee.
Wird's nicht spannend. Nee, ist eigentlich auch nicht spannend.
Wenn du denkst, weißt du, wenn du so irgendwie so Wochen wie die letzten vier, fünf Wochen hinter dir hast, ne, mit irgendwie Netzneutralität kaputt, Vorratsdatenspeicherung beschlossen, keine CCC-Videos aufm Apple TV.
Was kann dann noch kommen? Was, was kann dann noch kommen?
Wenn du dir denkst so, okay, was haben wir eigentlich noch so, also wir müssen ja auch hier, ne, mit unserem, mit unserem Businessmodell Logbuch Netzpolitik, wo wir, ne, müssen wir uns ja auch überlegen so,
Wie lange können wir überhaupt noch über Netzpolitik reden.
Wenn jetzt hier bald alle Wälder abgebrannt sind, dann gibt's, dann wird diese Sendung ja auch irgendwann äh sterben. Ja, Internet sowieso. Wir werden auf Apple hätten wir auf Apple Plattform hätten wir natürlich sowieso keine Chance,
Ja und dann denkst du dir irgendwann so, okay, worüber könnte man denn noch reden,
angerufen. Ich sage so, Oettinger, ey, wie sieht's aus, ne? Was machst du jetzt? Da sagt er, Urheberrecht.
Keine Sorge, keine Sorge, Linus,
Da haben wir auf jeden Fall Gesprächsbedarf. Da machen wir noch was, ja? Da da sorgen wir dafür, dass ihr nochmal äh ein paar Sendungen machen könnt. Urheberrecht. Örtinger hatte,
Es war jetzt fast eine Woche vergangen, ohne dass Oettinger irgendwie auf das Internet eingedroschen hat.
Das geht ja gar nicht.
Und jetzt kommen sie halt mit mit Urheberrecht.
So. Das kann ja nur das, ich meine, wenn du sie wenn du über die Wörter EU-Kommission und Urheberrecht in einem Satz hast, ne, dann weißt du schon so, ähm.
Kannste auf kommt jetzt nix Schönes mehr, ne?
Ja.
Äh
Es gibt von diesen, äh das ist die, der Entwurf wurde äh von einem äh Block äh geleakt. Ähm das irgendwie ganz interessant ist. Das ist irgendwie IP-Cat, also.
Cut mit K.
Cut. IP Cut. Ich weiß nicht genau, wofür das Cut steht, aber da ist eine Katze im Logo, also habe ich jetzt gedacht.
Kitten.
Ja, sie haben mehrere Katzen auf dem Ding. Also wie auch immer, so dieses IP-Cat äh Blog.
Hat diesen Entwurf äh geleakt und ähm zwar es gibt's noch nicht lange her, es gibt zwei erste
Stellungnahmen dazu, einmal von äh Leonard Dobusch, der das Thema des Urheberrechts ja immer sehr viel für für Netzpolitik org behandelt und eine äh zweite,
erste Reaktion von von Julia Reeder, die uns allen ja in wunderbarer Erinnerung ist von Lokbuch Netzpolitik, Folge,
Hundertfünfzig auf dem Camp. Äh Leonard nach ersten Draufblicken sagt, okay ähm.
Es gibt das, was er positiv erkennt, ist, dass hier gesagt wird, okay, es wird deutlich gemacht, dass es einen reform und einen harmonisierungsbedarf gibt.
So, okay, gut,
Also er sagt, das ist gut, dass sie das anerkennen, weil ja eigentlich die organisierten Rechteinhaber mit dem Status quo eigentlich ganz zufrieden sind. Ja, du hast jetzt kein äh
die urheberrechtsverwertungsindustrie bemängelt jetzt nicht unbedingt den Status quo.
Insofern sagt Leonard, das ist aber schon mal schön, dass äh.
Dass immerhin die Kommission sagt, es gibt einen Reformbedarf, aber jetzt kommt der der äh spannende Teil ähm das Leistungsschutzrecht findet sich wieder da drin.
Unser Freund.
Und natürlich, wie man so was am Anfang macht.
Noch relativ vage. Und da kommen jetzt eigentlich die beiden zu unterschiedlich dramatischen Auslegungen äh dieses,
ähm dieses Textes. Ähm beide bemerken, dass es quasi einen einen Satz gibt, der sagt.
Für News Aggregatoren wurden einige Lösungen in EU-Staaten Mitgliedsstaaten ausprobiert.
Die aber das Risiko einer größeren Fragmentierung des digitalen Marktes bergen. So.
Der Satz heißt, der Satz heißt.
Im Prinzip, dass Leistungsschutzrecht war ein Versuch.
Das Problem zu lösen, es gibt also eine implizite Anerkennung, dass es ein Problem gibt und kritisiert wird nicht, dass diese Dinger unsinnig sind,
sondern kritisiert wird, dass sie versucht wurden, nicht funktioniert haben und ein Risiko der weiteren Fragmentierung des Marktes beinhalten. Deswegen solle man doch besser,
Ähm die nationalen Leistungsschutzrecht Initiativen auf einer EU-Ebene umsetzen,
Damit hier nicht wieder, ne, eine Fragmentierung des Marktes auftritt.
Die Harmonitarisierung sichergestellt ist.
Genau.
So und die Julia geht in ihrer Interpretation noch ein bisschen weiter, weil ja quasi.
Eine Unklarheit besteht, wo jetzt die öffentliche Zugänglichmachung anfängt. Und es gibt ein sogenanntes Swenson-Urteil des Europäischen Gerichtshof,
in dem festgestellt wurde, dass das bloße Verlinken öffentlich zugänglicher Inhalte keine Urheberrechtsverletzung darstellt. Ja, also wenn etwas öffentlich zugänglich gemacht wird, dann ist,
Das Linken auf diesen Inhalt, keine Urheberrechtsverletzung.
Und sie interpretiert den Text so, dass die Kommission beabsichtigt, genau das zu ändern. Also die Unklarheit, was ist öffentliche Zugänglichmachung,
dahin zu verschieben, dass Linken dazugehört. Und dadurch hätte die EU-Kommission eine sehr klare Handhabe, ein Leistungsschutzrecht umzusetzen, indem man nämlich den,
Verlegern im Prinzip das Recht gibt, zu entscheiden, wer darauf linken darf.
Wir erinnern uns, dass deutsche Leistungsschutzrecht ist dadurch umgesetzt,
Ähm dass Inhalte nicht gestohlen werden dürfen, ja. Du darfst darauf lenken und das Leistungsschutzrecht bezieht sich darauf, dass du nur kleinste Textfragmente stehlen darfst, weil du sonst das Urheberrecht,
das Leistungsschutzrecht des Verlegers verletzt. Aber du.
Kleinste Textausschnitte heißt es da.
Kleinste Textausschnitte. Aber du darfst trotzdem linken. Ja? Und über.
Über die Option, den Presseverlag das Recht einzuräumen, zu entscheiden, wer Linken darf und wer nicht.
Hätte man halt eine deutlich bessere, also aus Verlagssicht deutlich bessere Möglichkeit äh sein Leistungsschutzrecht geltend zu machen. Das ist die Gefahr, die sie hier sieht und sie sagt natürlich auch ganz klar,
Wenn du also dann ist halt aller Tage arm. Dann ist halt vorbei, ne.
Dann kann man das Web eigentlich jetzt auch sein lassen.
Dann kannst du's auch echt sein lassen, dann hast du die Essenz des Webs kaputt gemacht.
Und dann ist gut. So, dann kannst du sagen, dann machen wir jetzt Facebook. Ne, die Verlage veröffentlichen ja eh schon jetzt direkt auf Facebook ihre Inhalte.
Und dann ist gut. So und dann verbietet Apple noch demnächst äh von Apple runterzulinken oder sowas. Also ne,
Also dann ist ist halt vorbei, so wie ne, jetzt als absolute Schwarzmalerei.
Ja, davor wird gewarnt. Ich meine, kann grundsätzlich davor gewarnt werden, wenn irgendwie die EU irgendwas anfassen will und wenn's das wenn's jetzt das Urheberrecht in der Form ist, ähm erst recht, aber jetzt,
Leistungsschutzrecht auf EU-Ebene ist sicherlich nicht unbedingt das, was wir.
Nee, weil das hat sich ja nun auch wirklich in Deutschland gezeigt, dass es einfach auch wirklich am Ende überhaupt nichts gebracht hat, außer Ärger. Also es ist so niemand, niemand verdient irgendwie Geld damit,
Ja, Google wurde sozusagen ein Freibrief äh ausgestellt, ja,
Damit hat man sich sozusagen Google auch als einzigen
Teilnehmer äh in diesem speziellen Newsverlinkungsmarkt einfach zementiert und alle anderen einfach mal rausgeschmissen
Ob das nun wirklich die eigentliche Intention äh hätte auch nur sein dürfen. Also da da komme ich überhaupt auch von vom Gedankenmodell einfach nicht mehr hinterher. Also in ihrem Wahn,
ihr äh ist in dem Fall die Verleger. In diesem Verleger waren
alles mögliche zu monetarisieren, ohne eine eigene Leistung wirklich zu erbringen, findet man eben ein Leistungsschutzrecht, zwingt die Bundesregierung dazu, das irgendwie auch noch durchzusetzen mit äh der entsprechenden Medienmacht, dass das so gelaufen ist, denke ich, haben wir hier ausreichend,
dokumentiert und am Ende äh erreicht man gegen den eigentlichen Endgegner, den man die ganze Zeit ausgerufen hat, genau, überhaupt nichts.
Ja, aber man hat halt so mal eben noch Schalom alle irgendwie erdenklichen, anderen Modelle äh gleich,
mit umgebracht. Und wenn man jetzt diese zweite Stufe zündet und sozusagen auch noch das soweit denkt, naja, wenn das nicht funktioniert, dann müssen wir halt noch mehr verbieten. Ja und das ähm ja. Ich habe da eine gewisse Hoffnung. Ich bin ja äh Berufsoptimist,
dass äh hier der EuGH äh ähm wenn er schon mal in die eine Richtung ähm entsprechend entschieden hat, auch äh hier dem einen Riegel vorschieben könnte.
Abwarten wie diese ganze Debatte läuft.
Auf jeden Fall Herr Öttinger ist ist einfach die Plage, von der wir schon von Anfang an dachten, dass er sie sei und beweist es einfach.
Mädels um einiges, es ist um einiges schlimmer. Ich finde es um einiges schlimmer, als ich erwartet habe. Es ist wirklich um einiges schlimmer, aber ich bin diese Woche ehm.
Auf nichts gut zu sprechen.
Auf, also auf diesen ganzen.
Haufen.
Ja. Eine Vollkatastrophe. Kommen wir zu dem, was wir Epilog nennen, Tim. Kommen wir zum Ende.
Zum Ausatmen,
Wir machen jetzt hier keinen Terminblock auf, aber uns erreichte noch der Hinweis auf die No Spike Konferenz, die vom dreizehnten bis fünfzehnten November in Stuttgart im Literaturhaus äh,
stattfindet,
geht's um gesellschaftliche philosophische und politische Aspekte von Überwachung, Demokratie, Geheimdienstkontrolle, Möglichkeiten der digitalen Selbstverteidigung,
Punkt org. Darauf sei jetzt hier an dieser Stelle nochmal hingewiesen.
Ist eine Unkonferenz. Nun gibt's auch eine Fakt zu, ja ähm schön, empfehlen wir. Kommt der Oettinger nicht aus Stuttgart.
Hm. Ausm, ich weiß nicht, ob er aus Stuttgart selber ist.
Na ja, der kommt wahrscheinlich von irgendeinem Bauernhof, aber.
Jeden Fall dem Lindle. Oettinger, ich gucke mal. Ah, ist ein Stück.
Komm, ich finde da nur die Brauerei. Ja. Könnten wir den Maien einladen?
Geboren. Ja. Tatsache. Könnten wir den meinen? Hm. Der war ja auch mal Ministerpräsident. Das vergisst man ja auch, ne.
Und dann der hat Affen, der hat Zeug auf dem Körper.
Schlimm.
Echt, wir haben's schwer mit dir, das ist,
Es ist auch immer, ich meine, ist auch manchmal ganz gut, wenn man einfach
auch ein definierten Feind hat. Ich meine, wenn uns jetzt mal alle Feindbilder abhanden kommen würden, so, aber es gibt einfach auch gerade keinen Mangel.
Ich habe echt, nein, das ist nicht mein Feind. Das ist, ich will einfach nur, dass der in in irgendeine sichere Verwahrung kommt. Ich habe nix gegen den Menschen.
Ich habe Mitleid eigentlich mit dem, aber es kann halt nicht sein, also ne, unser Mitleid kann halt nicht dahin führen, dass der hier irgendwie alles in in Schutt und Asche legt, nur weil er irgendwie halt.
Ich meine, er hat ja bei mehreren man liest ja mal den Wikipedia Artikel durch.
Ja, es ist einfach dieses Elend, das macht einen einfach fertig.
Tut mir schon leid, aber ich kann jetzt nicht irgendwie die Europäische Union opfern, nur weil ich Mitleid mit dem Typen da habe.
Ja, das ist doch offen. Kundig, dass der Mann irgendwie Hilfe braucht. So herzlos kann man nicht sein, dass man kein Mitleid mit Günther Öttinger hat.
Ich würde sagen, wir verabschieden uns. Bis bald. Bis bald.
Ja. Okay, machen wir das. Bis bald. Habt eine schöne Woche.